what would happen if you dumped one of
the world's coldest liquids into the
boiling volatile mouth of a volcano
would it freeze all the lava inside
could it cause a massive explosion or
maybe trigger a major natural disaster
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we dumped liquid nitrogen into
a volcano first things first if you're
planning to put on your protective gear
and dump a bucket of liquid nitrogen
into a volcano
you're going to be disappointed before
you could even get close to the mouth of
the volcano the liquid nitrogen would
evaporate due to the extreme heat so
you'd have to be a little more creative
one way you could do it would be to fill
a bunch of cannon balls with liquid
nitrogen and launch them all into the
volcano at once that would definitely
start a reaction inside the volcano but
you probably wouldn't want to stick
around to see it now before you go
mixing these two crazy things together
let's get to know them a little better
on the one hand you have volcanoes which
are basically giant holes in the Earth's
crust they're full of boiling hot magma
that can erupt outwards in the form of
lava actually boiling is an
understatement because lava can reach
temperatures of up to 1,200 degrees and
on the other hand you have liquid
nitrogen the smoky looking substance
that most people have heard of but don't
know much about it can be as cold as
minus 210 degrees and when it warms up
and becomes a gas it expands to 175
times its volume if we want the liquid
nitrogen to have a noticeable impact on
the volcano we're going to need millions
of liters of the stuff
but no big deal large masses of liquid
nitrogen can be produced commercially
and all we'd need to transport it would
be vented and insulated containers to
prevent pressure buildup the really hard
part would come when you try to put
those millions of liters of liquid
nitrogen into the volcano that brings us
back to the cannonballs the idea is that
you'd fill each cannonball with liquid
nitrogen and blast it into the mouth of
the volcano when the cannonball melts
due to the extreme heat it will release
the liquid nitrogen into the magma yeah
we realize this is getting ridiculous
but hey you knew what you were signing
up for once a few cannonballs reached
the magma there would be a deadly brew
of heated nitrogen gas floating its way
up and out of the volcano gobbling up
all the oxygen around it as it rises the
liquid nitrogen might be able to freeze
the surface lava quickly enough to form
a crust but that still wouldn't be a
very exciting effect for you watching
from outside the volcano now if you were
somehow able to line up thousands of
nitrogen cannons and continuously fire
copious amounts of liquid nitrogen into
the volcano then things would start to
get interesting with this amount of
liquid nitrogen more than just the
surface lava would start to freeze and
immense pressure would build up
underneath beneath the mouths of the
volcano there would be kilometers of
lava slowly making its way to the
surface its natural flow would be
stopped by the frozen top layer all that
pressure would need to go somewhere the
surface lava would at this stage looked
like a crumbling black sidewalk slowly
being elevated as love appears under it
finally explosions would begin
the volcano would erupt sending Jets of
atmospheric pollutants skyward
pollutants that could affect any living
creature in the vicinity or the volcano
might even explode causing an earthquake
essentially you'd be creating an induced
eruption a blocked vent is what causes
volcanic eruptions but generally those
blocks are natural so maybe you should
just keep the liquid nitrogen far away
from volcanoes and put it to better use
--is like culinary experiments
maybe there's a delicious dish waiting
to be discovered by a mixing liquid
nitrogen and lava together but that's a
story for another what if
[Music]